welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Candyman is Jordan Peele and
Nia to Costas sequel to the 1992 Tony
Todd horror classic like peels get out
and us Candyman
aims to terrify us with hidden details
you wish you didn't see deep-rooted
symbolism you didn't know and who
nineties hip-hop you wish you could just
hear at regular speed I'm gonna break
down this trailer frame by frame for all
the miserable Candyman sightings the
legend behind Candyman and how will
connect to this sequel it spoiler
warning in case any my predictions into
being right into hey do me a favor and
don't play this video in front of a
mirror because I'm already up to like
four Candyman mentions oh wait that's
five [ __ ] let's get started the urban
legend is if you say his name five times
by looking in the mirror he appears in
the reflection and it kills you so our
hero Anthony explains the Candyman urban
legend played by Yaya Abdul Mateen the
second from Watchmen Aquaman and us
Anthony McCoy is the adult version of
the baby from the first film son of Anne
Marie Vanessa a Williams who returned to
the sequel still looks great
we saw the original film Anthony was
nearly a victim of Candyman but he
escaped when Helen Virginia Matson
crawled him out of the fire Helen ended
up becoming part of the Candyman myth as
Anthony appears to in this movie
Anthony's girlfriend is played by Tiana
Paris Monica Rambeau from the MCU she
wears a deer necklace
perhaps a nod to be symbolic deer from
get out perhaps she too will transition
from endangered to hunter in this film
moving on
Candyman Kevin
Kanzi man so who would do this yeah
girls working on her tic TOCs there are
five girls summoning the Candyman one
girl for every time you say his name
this girl's name is hailey
he's probably the leader and most
frightening thing to them is black girl
walking in on a cultural appropriation
sadly Trina will probably have to take
the fall for these deaths usually when
the Candyman slaves someone bystander is
left behind to take the blame everyone
thinks they're crazy on to the next clip
let's go
so the girls hair ever so slightly tugs
upward just like that creepy moment and
it follows and then a bee buzzes around
clearly she spots something behind her
in her mirror and then later after the
slaughter we get the slightest glimpse
of the Candyman okay so according to the
legend explained in the 92 film the
Candyman was the son of a slave who
amassed wealth after the Civil War were
the way to mass-produce shoes
the son was well educated and made a
living painting portraits for high
society people until he fell in love
with a white woman and was attacked by a
lynch mob they cut off his hand covered
him in honey and caused him to be stung
to death by bees his body was burned in
his ashes were scattered in Chicago's
cabrini-green area now he lived on as a
murderous ghost popping up in mirrors
with gooey burned away skin smelling
like candy floss and using that silky
smooth Tony Todd voice to lure people
into being victims here Candyman has a
tan fur light trench coat the same
colors hand as this girl's jacket so I
think we might see a lot of tan cloth
mr. X in this film oh that flash the tan
fabric wasn't the Candyman it was a high
jacket oh wait no I'm dead next clip I
feel really connected to this
neighborhood cabrini-green it was the
project's that just moved in around the
corner the old candy factory
okay so Chicago's cabrini-green was an
infamous public housing project that due
to the city's racist housing policies
descended into a slum it was the setting
of the 92 film and in the year 2011 the
cabrini-green high-rises were torn down
leaving hundreds of row houses and
nowadays the community is facing a new
kind of threat gentrification caused by
people like well yeah it seems Anthony
who is a well-off artist who claims the
connection to the area but doesn't
really fully appreciate the trauma and
now it's kind of exploiting that history
is that okay I don't know it's
definitely not for me to say anyway as
Anthony snaps photographs the flash
briefly shows graffiti of the Candyman
his appearance here is from Clive
Barker's original short story about the
character moving on I'm an artist you
look up again
he's the monster it's part of this
neighborhood
why are you drawn to this I'm hoping to
spread the story all about Candyman the
mirror invites you to summon him okay
Anthony's Candyman themed art exhibit
includes a painting that displays
Candyman stink swollen face and then a
mirror where he can summon him seems
like a big mistake on word you should
say his name I dare you
Candyman Candyman Candyman Candyman
don't say - and then we get another
flashes hand fabrics shown in the mirror
another will appear later the bathroom
perhaps here's some more Candyman mr. X
being set up here and the audio mixes in
the sounds of buzzing bees and a montage
shows for candy mans
back-to-back-to-back-to-back with
anne-marie cutting us off before we get
to the fist
Candyman Candyman Candyman
I have really got a bookmark this
Vanessa clip just shut people up when
they just go on and on and on and they
never got it moving on
candy me
here Kahneman kills this couple he
appears in the shadow of the background
his hook slicing the projector screen
and then you'd see him creeping up on
the dude in the reflection of the glass
door and then as the guys dragged back
you could see can't even shadow on the
wall behind him lighting not walking in
his head later he cuz he's cocked to the
side he seems to be moving an
exaggerated performative style similar
to Lupita Nyong'o his physicality has
read in us the mirror shows Candyman
lifting and gutting the guy and he could
see the dude's toes grasping at his
lovers fingers perhaps his shoe flying
off is connected to candy man's family
shoe business maybe I'm reading too much
into it but yeah yeah okay next lip to
get made a mistake amazing music here
it's a creepy mix of say my name my
Destiny's Child
just like the mix of I got five on it
nuts say my name applies of course to
the Candyman myth of saying his name but
Beyonce's followers are also called what
the Beehive and underneath say my name
is an organ melody this is actually
Philip Glass's original theme from the
92 film these details can be easy to
overlook you know sometimes they just
blend in seamlessly with the curves and
contours of their surroundings they're
discrete much like the sponsor of this
episode though Ridge Ridge makes
everyday goods to a standard you don't
see every day they streamline your life
by turning the things you carry like
backpacks chargers and wallets and two
tools for a better living and their
flagship product is the ridge wallet it
was launched on Kickstarter in 2013 and
now sits in the front pockets of over
half a million men and women my wallet
used to be stuffed full of crap that I
didn't need anymore and it was giving me
back trouble not anymore this is their
aluminum wallet in the raw color they
have other colors including some very
flashy Tiki designs
it's liked it's strong it has a cool
industrial chic vibe the ridge is a
minimal front pocket wallet that's
designed to streamline what you carry
every day
it has 30,000 five-star reviews and is a
better way to carry your cash in your
cards there's a lifetime warranty if you
love it and three returns if you don't
it comes in titanium carbon fiber
aluminum and over a dozen different
styles and colors they also have great
backpacks and travel bags with RFID
blocking pockets and optional device
charging batteries get 10% off today
with free worldwide shipping in returns
by going to rigid comm slash new Rox
that's rich comm slash new rockstars and
use the code new rockstars find the link
in the video's description
Anthony's reflection shows him as
Candyman suggesting that this character
may actually be becoming the bogeyman
this artist for elites transforming into
an artist from elites from a previous
generation it's hard to tell but his
eyes look blacked out like the figures
in the exhibit film real as if his
Candyman self is waiting to reveal
himself notice Anthony's hand is wounded
here perhaps that bee sting he received
is gonna rot and rot until he
straight-up has to sever his hand
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
loses himself in his work in gives us
another solid reaction gift Candyman
appears again to the girlfriend in bed
and then in the mirror behind the other
woman and then we see that women die
from a distance with similar voyeuristic
framing as Hitchcock's rear window and
the need further transforms into
Candyman as another Candyman figure
takes out bones out of his hand and we
hear boys saying item the writing on the
wall with the demonic voice reminding us
of a seductive lers made by Tony Todd in
the original film The Lion it's also
another connection to say my name
the Destiny's Child song was on the
album the writing's on the wall as the
girlfriend runs into Candyman in the
darkness pervading lights up showing his
figure with his ribs exposed reflecting
how Katie man's chest has burned away to
expose the ribcage next clip
Laura do this cabrini-green Church has a
doorway with the open mouth design
similar to the portal into candy mans
chamber in the 92 film bees swarm in
there you can see the words sweet to the
sweet on the wall another call back to
the original production design and
there's this woman watching with a
wreath of flowers on her head reminding
me a lot of the creepy ritual at the end
of midsummer in which spoiler the
girlfriend watches as her man gets
mutilated and then as Anthony faces the
police notice his reflection in the car
window his face has transformed into
Tony Todd Candyman meanwhile the voice
calls out be my victim but he lingers on
be oh yeah candy mans puns are so sweet
yeah sorry we've been on in the last
clip
[Music]
and we are left with this boy peeking
into a candy man attack blood bees his
hook pulling back the shower curtain I'm
thinking this film may show us other
past Candyman incidents as people are
perpetuating the myth this could be a
really good opening scene comment down
below with what scares you most about
this trailer enjoying the discussion on
our official discord becoming a patron
follow me on instagram and twitter at da
boss fall of new rock stars and
subscribe dinner arc sirs here on
YouTube for breakdowns of everything you
love thanks for watching
[Music]